hey guys welcome back to another episode
of the swoosh what led podcast super
grateful for all of what led's partners
who continue to help make this podcast
happen and if you're new to the podcast
and unsure what swish is well let me
tell you it is a super cool platform
which allows you to get a video message
from some of your favorite sports stars
and with mother's day around the corner
here's a chance for you to get your mum
one for mother's day imagine giving your
mum a mother's day message from the
great jackson garden bishop all for 20
bucks and a large portion of that goes
to kiwi kids charities and you can also
make it even cheaper by getting an extra
10 off that price by using the code mum
10 and i'll leave a link in the
description so you just have to go click
on that it is super easy and your mum
will be super stoked with you also as i
sit here on this cold evening sipping my
favorite cup of pomeroy's tea it reminds
me of another great idea for mother's
day if your mum loves a good cup of
coffee or a good cup of tea then here's
a chance for you to become her favorite
son order any of the pomeroy's wide
range of teas or coffee and you can get
an extra 20 off your order using the
code lead03 i'll leave a link in the
description below so you can have easy
access to the code
special thank you to all the sponsors
very much appreciated but now it is time
to get to the main event let's roll the
intro
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh what a tune well i have another
absolute treat for you all with one of
the most promising players in new
zealand rugby who also happens to be one
of the biggest lads going around he was
a schoolboy sensation making all the new
zealand age-grade teams he was then
picked up extremely young by the
wellington lions and the hurricanes he's
represented the new zealand maldives and
he now plays as provincial footy for
hawke's bay he is the pride of gizzy it
is isaiah walker lewedy welcome mate
thanks for having me jeff it was weird
i've never really called you by your
full first name like that that was a bit
bit odd it's always been is he from
gizzy for me yeah well no one really has
either
i'm sure most people don't even know
what my real name is
when did you get your nickname oh that
was um
our last year's school i did that um we
knew canes came up boys came up to the
gazillion for camp yeah and then skuck
sort of just gave me the nickname and
then it's stuck ever since true
oh i thought you had it from when you
must have been a weak kid but you got it
then
yeah
i just ran all the day and i was like
yeah well guys gave me it
right well he says go he's hey
yeah especially when you're young and
you're like yeah
yeah your hero a just gives you this
nickname
oh that's cracker but mate awesome to
see you back playing been a long rehab
period for you
back-to-back games on absolute fire
straight from the get-go how's it felt
oh the body's banged up at the moment
but it's been good just to get a
run around the boys finally again yeah
and your form's been on fire you're
obviously doing the work during your
rehab period
doing all the hard yards yeah well you
know lee van he's got me on this the gun
show program so
i'm hopefully hopefully he is as big as
him
well chrono chrono's got big guns too eh
oh he's he's different kind of breeder
but how did you find that rehab period
um
well it's kind of weird at the start i
thought i was gonna be out for the whole
season
so
at the start of that i was just like
just eating whatever i wanted to be
honest
wasn't it really doing any training
and then about i had like a three month
checkup
and then they're like oh you could be
back in april and i was like
oh yeah
so then i
had them get in shape real quick okay so
it was actually a fun enjoyable process
yeah yeah so what was it was initial
diagnosis 12 months and then it what got
cut to six was that yeah the initial was
um yeah 12 months
and then
after surgery it was nine months yeah
and then
like three months
um checkup
they reckon oh you could be back in like
three three months and i was like
oh man
probably good thing
wait what a rehab from you what were you
doing how did you do that
oh
just jumped on there why suck in the
hole of fijian leaves
did you try something like that did you
try something alternative no i just
i don't know just happened out of the
blue real oh that's crazy but that's
cool so then once you found out that you
were um only three months away you
obviously had to get your act into gear
pretty quick yeah i was well the boys
were already starting pre-season so
that helped
they helped with like the process of
being around like everyone still
like if i was alone i probably would
have struggled a lot more
because you are like a
cruisy guy yeah you've always been a
real cruisy character i've heard a lot
of guys talk about how they dealt with
their time being injured what what are
you like you're pretty chilled out not
not too much sort of phases yeah yeah i
wasn't really faced too much
it just meant i could
hang out like my daughter and
spend a bit more time with my family so
that was that was probably the positive
part of it yeah how's that been
obviously a new dad now
exciting times for anyone and i guess
they make you grow up pretty quick
yeah they definitely do make you grow up
weekends have changed a bit
a lot less sleep as well i've noticed
and have you found it no it's been good
it's been real enjoyable um yeah it's
like
just a little version of yourself pretty
much and yeah yeah and you get to i
guess choose how their future goes and
how their life plans out so
that's been fun
biggest adjustment for you
um
the weekend
probably like
probably the last
say after the game on the weekend
getting home
and i was pretty naked and then
but you
you just go back to dead life there's no
really
yeah
they don't care how your 80 minutes
winter
how many times
so how how old is she now
uh she's two two in a bit now yeah sure
so she's like
into everything yeah jumping off stuff
freaking
injuring everything right
just like the old man have you got plans
or any more
oh we'll we'll see [ __ ] oh
[Laughter]
check the spanner in there
announcement video
[Laughter]
gender reveals
oh but speaking of um kids and growing
up i'm pretty keen to hear about what
life was like for you growing up in
gizzy
awesome part of the world give us a
rundown on what life was like for you
well
i was actually i'm brought up in
ruratoria up in the east coast
spent all my childhood all my family
stood up there
spent most of it on the farm
wasn't really into rugby growing up i
was just
more like
just something to do for fun just
running around in bare feet and
you know used to watch the
old man play club rugby yeah and then
all the kids on the sideline we'll have
our own game
but yeah um went to primary school with
manutahi it's closed down now because
there's not really much people up there
now
um
spent
my year 1910 at um
natal memorial college
which is in rotorua yeah and in
yeah year 11
moved to gizzy boys and then that was
pretty much the start of my rugby
journey yeah did you move there because
of rugby
um yeah well um i follow our coach was
tom kings and um
he had been up the coast watching a few
of our games and
he sort of
took me into moving the boar's eye so
always grateful for him he's been um
he started everything for me
so were you good when you were coming
through the age groups even as a young
fella were you you're probably way
bigger than everyone else were you yeah
i was a lot bigger than everyone i was a
lot skinnier than i am now too
i was uh well when i was younger i used
to play fullback right until
i played fullback actually until i moved
to gizzy boys did you oh all the way
through
hey what's your game like oh
you know you've seen me a training gym
tony for a good job good good drop kick
[Laughter]
so why did you move to lock then or
why'd you move into the pack that would
have been a hard move
well
backs weren't really bred the same
height as jordy barrett was back then
so i sort of grew a bit we tall put on a
bit away and then
there's like yep you're playing locked
now
and i was like
so were you pretty were you keen to move
in into the um site stuff oh i don't
really mind uh
backward at school is more like just
playing with the boys
playing because it's fun and just
enjoying the time man
hey you're just too crazy how you just
go wherever someone tells you
yeah
well if alfie told me to play center
tomorrow
[Laughter]
what a big midfield that would
i'll probably be a bit slow
but you're old man you mentioned your
old man before um not everyone will know
but he played for fiji didn't he so he
was a pretty gun union player as well
yeah when i was younger he played like
from 99 to like 2002 for east coast oh
yeah
and then
it played like
i think it was two world cups for
fiji
so yeah it wasn't too bad
he played lock as well so oh yeah but
i was
a lot more skillful than he is
i think he gave me some talent
what sort of influence did he have on
your rugby career though
um
yeah as good as um just there's like
support i guess he didn't really forced
me into
playing rugby or anything it was just
if i was wanted to do it he'll just
support me
because watching games at east coast
watching east coast play at their home
ground is pretty special eh so you would
have been involved with all of that sort
of thing seeing your old man and be a
part of that as well
must be pretty hard to not get stuck
into rugby and not love the game yeah
well rugby is like uh i'll just say
it's like a religion up on the east
coast like the community comes together
every weekend the east coast hasn't been
that good like
past years but like the people and the
support will always still be there so
that's the kind of good thing about
being from
up there here would you ever play for
east coast i've actually talked about it
with a few boys about going back and
playing one day so hopefully hopefully
one day
right how good would that be
so good are you what's it like when you
go back there and um see everyone are
you like a bit of a hero bit of a god
you're the king of east coast aren't you
oh
everyone knows how to play footy but
they all sort of just no one really
cares
if you picture me everyone saw like me
like relaxed like
that is a cool thing but even other
sports like growing up i heard you're
quite good at basketball too which i
find hard to believe after watching you
shoot a few bricks and a few one-on-one
games with tj oh
back in my heydays
i was um
i actually had the
opportunity to go to the boys for um
basketball did
yeah i was like you would go to writers
for
babel go together for rugby so
thankfully i chose rugby but
who knows i might have been stephen
adams before stephen adams imagine that
so we were that good at basketball i was
alright all of themselves gone yeah
yeah and what were you like at rugby at
that age did you think you were a pretty
good chance of making a job out of it i
wasn't i didn't really know you could do
that like in the case
i'd never like picture doing it as like
a life like a life job it was more just
playing with footy with the bros yeah
that's what was
yeah when did that start to change
obviously you started making all these
teams
um everyone wanted your signature from
about the age of 16 wanting you on their
books
when did you know that hey this could
actually be something it was um
well making all the eight great teams
was pretty like eye-opening
like most of the boys that are in the
team now that i did all age raid with
and
like played with them so but not to
maybe they can't win news when the kings
boys came up to gizzy and i was like
wow
this could actually be like an actual
thing yeah so they made me want to more
i guess yeah so speaking of that camera
that was pretty crazy so you were still
at school at the time hurricanes are
training up and are having a pre-season
camp up in gizzy
um and you come along train with them
for the week and you just fit in like
your old experienced veteran super rugby
veteran i won't even notice the 17 or 18
year old kid was training with us
i actually got a funny story from um
their campaign
i remember we've i think we're playing
kong games or something and i was like
too scared to jump in the middle so i
like stand on the edge
and then um skux through a mist pass to
me and i went in and i wasn't there to
like catch it like it was in front of me
and then he was like
get her up and wing on there like get it
buddy hung over
no mucking around
and is that when he gave you the
nickname to make up for it
true oh that's hard case but what was it
what was it like what was it like
training with the rest of the boys like
being amongst that at that age i was
pretty good at it because um i sort of
knew like blade and tour and it just
because they've been in and out of like
busy because they've old disney boys
um
so it was good like i could hang out
with them
but i like get to know everyone else as
well yeah crazy so good and then you
made like new zealand schools you made
new zealand 20s couple of trips for you
um at an early a pretty young age i'd
imagine these were sort of your first
trips out of new zealand and what were
you like on tiller oh
he could ask everyone i was trouble man
this young kid from the east coast
flying on planes
for rugby i was like
i was just crazy
what'd you get out
oh from like missing freaking meetings
to
just
trying to look at everything
i was like amazed
the biggest place i went to for rugby
was like gusman now i'm afraid
and aussie we played school boys in
aussie and the goldie and i was just
like
wow where am i
surface paradise i was like
this is too big for me
yeah that's funny you talk about like
the professionalism of it all because
like you say like you've mentioned
you're such a cruisy guy you've just
always enjoyed playing rugby just to
play with your mates and then suddenly
you're in the sort of whole professional
part of the game where it's so serious
you can't miss meetings and stuff how
did you find the adjustment to that i'm
so adjusting now
now when i first came down i was like
my first couple of years i was just too
scared to like miss anything yeah so i
was like getting alarms and everything
old meeting i'll miss
but i remember my first week of like
academy when i first moved to wellington
yeah i was like because academy is so
hard man like
you're trained from like six to eight
and then you're straight to work
straight after yeah and then like the
second day
i slipped past through my alarm
and i was like so scared i driving into
the academy and i was like damn i'm late
good old lady was our
academy manager back then and he was
sweet as a
but after that man i learned quick
how long were you in the academy for
because i sort of thought you skipped
that whole part of the
rugby scene you i sort of thought you
went straight into the hurricanes in
wellington yeah no i was only doing it
for like a month
[Laughter]
craig i've always come on this is
outside i do not remember when i used to
be a trainee i used to
be a builder and it's just like you're
done there for two weeks relax
oh so it was building is that what you
were gonna do
yeah i was gonna do building and then
border gave me the call and he was like
someone's injured we need a trainer and
i was like oh yeah sweet ass told my
boss and he was like oh yeah
the latest
[Laughter]
never been back
never been back never going back to it
oh that's classic but you made new
zealand 20s as well and you made it a
year young from memory what was that
like
oh that was
that's a huge surprise eh
because um usually that they picked the
squad from like the oceania comp before
and i i i got injured so i like
fractured my eye or something
and then
so the boys went all the way to there
and then like a week later after they
got back
they named the team for the world cup
and then i just seen my name in there
and i was like oh well because i was
like still coming back from injury and
then yeah so
the first year was like a blu-ray so
but it was good fun we went to
manchester i think it was we actually
had a good team
even though or back then we're like
the worst result or something
for our team for the 20s ever yeah
so
our team was known as the worst team
ever well we actually had some gun
players eh
who stood out
well obviously geordie
yeah daughter was in there belinda
upside was there yeah um
where
marina dalton
tj var sam knock sean stevenson
we're like a pretty good team
but just results didn't go our away so
did you get feedback from the coaches
going into that that you were in the
frame or was that just completely out of
the blue
i was completely out of the blue i was
like
i wasn't expecting to see my name yeah
but then i just kept getting
notifications on my phone
and then i was like hey
and i just clicked on it
and i see my name i was like oh my gosh
i was so happy at the time yeah well
like surprised there's a surprises and
was it intimidating going in there being
a year younger or
age doesn't really matter at that level
no
it was real it was real good because we
had like seven or eight of us that were
a year young oh yeah yeah so there was a
few and i already knew like all the ones
and boys like tj marlow and that
so it was actually all goods yeah and
then touring to manchester this boy from
the east coast
you talked about the gold coast
manchester would have been a whole new
level for you
oh
different
weather as well
it's like pretty much raining overcast
like every day i was like
come on man
give me back to good old son and leave
do you guys get to did you guys get to
go out much or anything or did you get
up too much stuff off the field and
those sort of tours um yeah there's a
few like malls around
um because we were pretty much staying
in like
in the city
so
it was pretty easy just to go on like
four walk
just with the mates or just some of the
teammates here walks and walls sounds
awesome
but
you spend most of your time training so
yeah
true and then the following year you
you're obviously probably expecting to
make it this year and you make it this
time you're off to georgia
what experience that would have been
oh i was georgia's country was like
pretty food world like
it was like broken down
buildings like
mansions that are abandoned
it's pretty run down to be honest but it
was pretty good because like
we just stuck together as a team like
we're pretty much staying out in the
warps and then we only had each other
yeah so like it just brought us together
better i reckon and had some success on
the field as well right
yeah we're
our team was real
stick i'd say now like to where the boys
are right now we had like a real stick
team
heard you have yeah oh we're like
a young will jordan
caleb
dalton
uh luke jacobson was our captain yeah
we're brighton ignore
steven peter we're oh
we're quality
we have peeps and peeps players right
and any any good stories from um either
those tours and what's the tournament
like when you finish it i know you love
a beer so
oh it was probably
oh i'll tell you a story here here we go
yeah
well we went to um
so we have this big dinner for like
after tony stuff we rock up all the
teams have gone into this massive
building and we have to come and last
because like we won yeah but outside the
building it would have been like a good
five minute long table
and there's just drinks after drinks
after drinks
and then it's only our team outside and
the boys are cheering at it like
going at it
it was so good man then we we got inside
everyone got to our tables
and then these waiters started bringing
out bottles of jameson's to our tables
yeah
and then so the boys were hoeing into
there
and then
we jumped into the bus
and we actually we actually went to a
concert on our way home
who was that so
oh no it was like a describe it as like
a mini rmv
so like the boys stopped at this
festival
jumped out and we were going crazy
the boys are all
the boys are on top of the moon just
want to calm
and then you let them loose at a
freaking festival
and there's a few like
the bus on the way home was like spewi
everywhere
it was crazy
you would have to lead the charge at the
um festival because i know you're an rmv
legend um everyone talks about you when
they mention the word rmv you're a known
myth up there so um did you lead the way
there oh yeah
you have to you have to lead the way
you want to be as good off the field as
you are on it
oh
good times how many times did you go to
rmv by the way to become the legend of
rmv
um we were younger at school um we used
to actually like sneak into rmv do you
have to be 18 to get in you have to be
18 together but that you looked eighteen
million yeah my mates used to
try we figured out how to like slip
bands off wrists oh yeah so you loosen
them you get someone else go pick it up
and then slip it off slip it onto yours
and you you're away laughing
but yeah i think
everyone just puts
izzy from gizzy
and rnv together so
just because i'm from gizzy means i'm
i love rmb
[Laughter]
well that's good stuff okay well you did
speak about um your brief academy times
and then straight into the hurricanes
straight into wellington lions what was
that adjustment like for you um it was
pretty eye-opening eh like how
i think the biggest thing was getting my
time management right
from like
at school you pretty much go to school
and train after school to
at being your full-time job and
you having to
go to this meeting and then five minutes
later you gotta be in this meeting
and then you gotta go train
and then the worst thing was
making my own lunches
oh
oh sorry i was horrendous at making my
own lunch man
[Laughter]
and is that something you had to adjust
to obviously um diet probably you
probably put on weight easier than some
people
did you ever have struggles with that
yeah pretty much
every summer break
well summer break's the worst moment
because you have
you have christmas you have new years
and news as a festival yeah
and then you can go home and like no one
really cares
what diet you're on they're just cooking
whatever they want yeah so
it's just like
and i gained weight easy but
i could put on weight easy the hardest
bit is losing it
but
oh yeah i found um
trying to cut the bad stuff pretty hard
eh what like the takeaways the easy
options was it or is it just yeah you're
like
yeah more like the easy options like
it was so easy just uh
especially in wellington like
there's like kfc every second
block like
mcdonald's is pretty much well now it's
uber it's like yeah
don't even have to leave your house
so who are you living with
um
oh when i first moved down i moved in
with um
toby robson he was our media guy oh
yeah yeah because he was a pawneeky man
yeah so i moved in with him
for like a couple months is that where
you're so good at uh media yeah that's
why i love it man
i love good media
no yeah um
but
a few of the boys from school moved down
so
i moved i ended up moving in with them
for the rest of
my first year down there
and then
my partner in the the next year
how hard was that to be living with your
um schoolmates who obviously
they wouldn't care about things like
nutrition or
professional
diets or things like that how hard was
that
it was actually pretty good like because
my first year i knew i wasn't going to
play with the canes so
i'll sort of just like training and then
i like play club rugby and then enjoy my
weekend like yeah enjoy a good night out
and like just enjoy being young because
i knew i wasn't had no expectation of
playing
any sort of super rugby so i sort of
enjoyed my younger fresh years down
and then that was it that year you were
playing for
um wellington
yeah made my debut
i think there was four of us that
debuted on their game was
me
a sophomore peter
alex and camera
so we all um debuted together
which was pretty cool what was that like
did you feel ready
um
i didn't really know what to expect to
be honest
um
it was funny my actually first game for
the lions was
against hawke's bay
and then my first game for hawk spells
against lions
and how did you go how did you go on
that first one so i was supposed to be
on the bench
and then um
mark reddish pulled out of the game
so then i had to start
and then
after the first kickoff i was
that was good it was so fun
are you a nervous guy because um you're
obviously very cruisy chilled out do you
get nervous before games or are you
still literally just like playing with
your mates when you go out there no
matter what the stage
yeah i don't really
pay attention to like what situation it
is or what
even when we're like in game like
some boys are like panicking when like
something goes wrong but like i can just
brush her like
if i if i drop the wall i just like to
smile but just to forget yeah
that's cool that's a cool mindset to
have a
yeah well i'm lucky i guess lucky to
have it the cruisey nature love it but
then uh talk to me about your call up
into the hurricanes and your hurricanes
david
oh yeah
well
my debut didn't go too well we lost
who was that again oh we played on
camera i played the the brown beam in
canberra oh yeah it was about minus one
degrees
and i'm sitting on the bench
freezing my health
and then i get on
get on with like 20 minutes to go
and i was like
wow
this is
this is special man yeah
it was really um
it was way more physical way
then like modded 10 or like 20s or
anything
so that was like the big thing i noticed
but it was like it was real enjoyable
because
for the like two years before that i was
like like understudy to like michael
fitz and samuel elsie in them yeah and
to actually like debut with them
was like pretty mean a
yeah what what what were they like to
learn off
oh um i think they're good for me
because they
both professional and like
they like to enjoy themselves as well
yeah yeah they're real handy like to
have around
in my career
and now you obviously the big dog of the
canes big dog of that pack
um you must be [ __ ] passing on your
knowledge for all the young guys coming
through
yeah it feels weird man like
well
i'm only 25 but like i feel like i've
been around for
forever yeah yeah
and we do have like a fairly
like young team so
i just sort of like looking after the
young boys
i don't really speak much i don't really
have the best advice but
[Music]
well
often thought i might have the bitter
advice in the field so
but no yeah i sort of like like looking
after the boys yet
no doubt so what's some of your favorite
memories as a hurricane
um
well when the boys
won the comp
yeah i was lucky enough to be the injury
replacement and yeah that was a special
time man
that was like something i could always
remember
even though like
obviously i wasn't fully signed by like
just to be around it like
to experience
it makes me like actually want to
actually win one myself matt you will
this is the year yeah
well hopefully
hopefully mate hopefully you do what
about um some trips to south africa i
know you've always enjoyed your times in
south africa
yeah well
savark is
different as well so
good business class flight that's that
always helps yeah helps the airports too
[Laughter]
i'm missing out on a few airports these
days yeah true no south african traps
yeah no southern troops usually the boys
are like just keep me on the flight so i
can get to gold
[Laughter]
but south africa's um
i'd say the crowds at the games are
wild
like
you just hear them chirping at you
at you the whole game in like
running into the tunnel running out of
the tunnel just stuff getting
thrown at you but
i guess it's all part of the experience
which is good here
and how's the how's the team looking
this year have you have you found this
year's campaign obviously you've been
out injured for most of it uh managed to
get a couple of big shifts and since
your return how do you think the team's
looking
um
i think we've um we're tracking in the
right direction
obviously we're the hard part of the
hard part i guess
yeah
right right watery analogy
parts
but i think we're trekking in the right
direction like
we're getting well we just had the storm
week and
we've
like developed depth in our squad so
everyone had to like have a chance to
play and show what they've got so
i think we're tracking in the right
direction and um yeah well that helps
that tj's back like an experienced
game driver and
obviously arty's leading the way so
there's no one better to follow than
into yeah great two of the greats and
what are your thoughts on magic round
obviously it's a pretty cool concept all
the games at one ground
that's unreal i reckon
especially it's an it's an aussie so
that's even better
it falls on wellington are we like oh no
cancel a cancer
but no it's good
it'll be good um
hopefully the good crowds show up
it would be good to like
because i know league's obviously the
main sport
over there so it'd be good to give i
guess australians experience rugby yeah
how do you think the rugby is going at
the moment like the quality level of it
i think it's a it's been a lot more
faster this year
i think even though like the scoreboards
haven't been showing it
it's been a lot faster
yeah
everyone seems to be getting to the
lineups a lot quicker tempo seems to be
a big theme from a lot of teams and the
games do seem to have a lot more
ball and play than maybe the last few
years yeah
definitely um
i know that we've been pushed we've
always pushed the temper so
it's
everyone's playing like us now
how do you find it do you enjoy the
tempo is that probably a part where
you'd rather be slowed down a little bit
get some more big collisions going oh
i love
running rugby yeah i like
like i'm a tech minded kind of player so
i love it today
is it true you um injured your shoulder
from doing a chip and chase is that a
yarn or is that true
yeah well that's actually um true
[Laughter]
so we played we played maldives where we
played um i think it was fiji
and then the next week we had our club
ceremony
which
i wasn't actually out of play but i sort
of just stuck my way in there
and then started playing
and then
i happened to be on the edge somehow
and then
there was no one outside of me
so i was like
sweet
just put it on the fork
and then went up try to tap it
to one of my teammates
and then i just
got you pulled down
landed on my
and then i was on the ground going like
this
and then while my team was like
down the field carrying on playing
nearly scoring and i was just sitting
there like oh yeah yeah i shouldn't have
chipman chase
oh yeah it's nearly ended in a try so
it worked out but it didn't work out for
me
it was the right play for the team but
oh costly
team first you know came for a smart
obviously you've always had that
mentality so one thing you did speak
about was your time with the new zealand
maldives you're obviously a very proud
maori what was it like being pulled into
that side yeah
i remember when i first got named i was
just getting tagged and like
mr just from
so much like people from home
and it made me realize like who i'm
actually representing and like who like
actually like
supports
supports me as a person
so
when i first got named i was like
overwhelmed
yeah yeah because i remember speaking to
oh teddy black around it and he felt
like i mean he always wanted to be a new
zealand maori or a maori all black um
even more so than an all black it was
just that's what it meant to him to
represent his people like you say the
fun part about like being like when
you're in the environment is you
actually get to learn about like your
culture and like
the backgrounds of the meanings of
everything
we're like
it's good for some boys that like
didn't really get to grow up
experiencing it yeah so they're actually
like reconnecting with like where
they're from and
who they are and stuff so i think that's
the best part about being in the
environment yeah can you speak today
i can
understand like words but i can't like
fluently put a sentence together yeah
the next step oh that's going to be good
that's the next next step yeah and uh
we've already spoken to um big party
patty parkinson about a couple of tours
um front loading the week seemed to be
quite a um used term and i'd imagine you
and him together were a big part of that
yeah well
we're the founding members of um
landing the week
that was actually yeah
i was just like a few of us boys it was
like a first tour with the maoris away
and like we went to some unreal places
like we went to chicago brazil
and chile
yeah and we sort of thought we weren't
allowed to stock up on
alcohol at the end of the week so we
thought we'd start it at the week
because no one will think we'll be doing
it at the start of the week so so the
first
like first couple of nights we'll
go out and experience
the places so
there's a it was a good way of getting
to experience the
cities that were in here yeah what was
what were the cities like like obviously
some cool places yeah it was chicago
went to um we actually went to their
that game where klay thompson
shot like 11 threes and
a game or something it was the most
threes in a game or something you were
there yeah they were we're actually
we're watching the game
front loading yeah front loading
i won't say who i was but
um
yeah the americas american sports life
is different a it's
it's like something you have if you go
into it
you have to experience to get i think
what do they do so so much better than
we do here um
well the playlist a lot better
um
there's always something going on like
every break every
time out every
half time quarter there's always
something happening on the court
and then
i think just
the people the mer they're like real mad
about their sports uh
yeah you also
made a move up to hawke's bay which is
something which a lot of people want to
know a bit more about why did you make
the move up there why'd you leave
wellington
um
just closer to home man um being in
wellington and like
obviously you're with the canes in
wellington and then lions is still in
wellington it costs like 600 bucks to
like fly home
or like it's like seven eight hours to
drive
yeah
so i'd really go home so like only go
home like once or twice a year
so the thought of going closer to home
was like the big
key factor for me here
and how did you find it once you got up
there hawke's bay there's a few lads out
there
yeah no love today
the environments has seen the culture
discussing
the places like chileans like
beaches surrounded by beaches
which is the fun part so you get to get
out on the water and stuff but yeah it's
really really easy to get used to
and what's your contract
status at the moment you got how many
more years you got with hawke's bay and
how many more years with the hurricanes
um
well this must be a big announcement
now i just resigned two years with the
there it is i knew there was an
announcement coming i was hoping it was
going to be a baby
this is the second biggest news
with the canes oh that's awesome yeah
just signed on the dotted line and
got it over yeah right how good so
you're obviously loving your time there
in wellington and hawke's day yeah hello
man
i wouldn't really wouldn't want to be
anywhere else mate exciting time so
that's you locked in for a couple of
years that'll take you to what um 27
years old
prime prime time age
have you got any ambitions to get
overseas at all or not really
nah
not really um
i find it too much of a hassle
[Music]
i can't be bothered moving
so chilled out you just cannot be able
to
the place i'm at at the moment um
yeah i'm happy to be staying around
and talk to me about your international
ambitions because obviously you're a
highly promising player who's been sort
of touted as being promising for a long
time but you're sort of at that age now
where um your forms just i mean you only
been back for a little while but you
formed so good that you must be in some
sort of frame for that all black
selection you also got the eligibility
possibility to play for fiji as well
have you made up any decisions around
that
yeah well
resigning here has probably
made
me like think about it yeah but yeah
i've definitely
wanted to give the all blacks a a decent
crack
at least one more time and then see
where it goes but i'm really just
enjoying playing with my footy and
if it happens it happens i'm not really
too fussed
so talk to me about that rule so if you
play for fiji does that make it harder
for you to stay in new zealand and be
contracted with the hurricanes
yeah i'm not actually too sure about it
but
i think it's like um super rugby teams
only can have a certain amount of
players that
play for ever
yeah
yeah
i think that's how it goes but
because obviously the carrot of the 2023
world cup will be a pretty tempting one
to want to be at um whether it was with
the all blacks or with fiji but
um you're fully focused on the all
blacks tool
um further down the line and then
potentially i'm the following one if
nothing comes off that black jersey
between now and then yeah yeah that's
the plan of the month yeah how good have
you had any feedback from um the all
blacks or in particular your old man
john plum tree
no i haven't had anything i'm just just
taking a game by game and
if it happens it happens if it doesn't
then it's that's all good
fair enough mate looking forward to an
idea
mate you're a bolter you're a bolter for
the 2023 world cup for me oh
oh watch the back end of this conference
see this man on absolute fire but you
spoke about being a builder um you loved
your time building for a couple of weeks
any plans for life after footy yeah
there's no plans at all then
um
yeah i have no idea i'm just pretty much
fully invested in this rugby at the
moment and then when i get there i'll
see what happens
would you look to move back to the east
coast when you're finished is that where
you think you'll end up
yeah i'll definitely um
want to do something around like helping
out at the east coast rugby
definitely giving back would
be a big part of it when i retire
so yeah
hopefully help out in that area
right you are a lad oh such a lad well
anyway as always we've gone to instagram
for some questions where'd you go to it
twice because i lost the first lot but
it means we've got twice as many
questions which is good stuff for you is
he
first question who's the best drinker at
hawke's bay this one came from someone
who probably thinks he's a contender
jonah
he's got a partner now so
he's kind of winded down and he's not as
he's not as durable as he was once upon
time
well that's going to hurt him
i'd say like a falafel tower or danny
twala oh yeah
yeah those kids go good man
mate you've got some good drinkers out
there don't you okay next one why do
they call you the big cheese
oh it was just
well when i dyed my hair blonde
and then a little bit of the black grew
back oh like like it is now
everyone started calling me mints and
cheese
and then so
cheese sort of just stuck and then
must be because i'm a big big father
then they just put bigger the front of
it
well brandon smith seemed to make it
work so you probably can too
yeah we might have to get some
some commercial going around there a bit
of a collab commercial cola between the
two cheeses
let's see we'll be in melbourne so we'll
go to melbourne
mate you should honestly send them a dm
right now to see if you could catch up
with
another fellow cheese i actually think
we'll get we're going to the warriors in
melbourne because it's on monday
are you staying there yeah we got um the
brumbies after that so oh wow that's her
thing so you guys are going to go into
any other the union games as well um not
sure i'm not sure because you could fill
your boots after your game you could
watch four games of footy and go watch
the warriors
could be a hell of a weekend
a hell of a monday night
oh good stuff oh i'm looking forward to
seeing that cheese colab okay
um
how was it playing for panicky under
great new head coach reggie goods
reggie goods one of the greats
it was now a good day it's been it's
been a few years since
since i played for pornicki because i
made the move up to hawke's way
um it's good to just to get minutes
under um reggie's running a good cutter
is he he's
yeah they've set up like a
academy there so so boys are training
all all year round which is good yeah
right that's intense and intense for
club footy good on you reggie good
question okay then the next question is
from
uh woodlands major sponsor swoosh if you
could get a video shout out from any
person in the world who would it be and
why
oh that's tough probably um
adele beckham jr oh
look we kind of looked the same one
you can see him
his nickname's the cheese too
yeah i might have to go collab with him
as well
oh mate the deal was coming from this
podcast oh so good
let's start it now
okay next one would you this is a good
one would you rather sleep in chrono's
beard every night for a week or have one
bath with jason holland
[Music]
i'm thinking they won't they'll both
be not enjoyable at all
one bath wouldn't hurt would it
oh [ __ ] i'd love to see you an alfie in
a bath now
oh this is going to be clipped in
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh i love it okay next one
how often do you think about the size of
space
saw space
[Music]
maybe every weekend
not too often i'd say
i don't really i don't really think
about much
oh some people have stitched up with
some of these good stuff okay um best
player that you've ever played with
i'd say
ari
he leads on the field man
yeah he leads by action
and what's he what's he like around the
changing rooms what's he like what's he
like in the environment yeah it's good
for the vomit um because obviously like
him and his social presence is like
he just likes to express himself
so he kind of lets everyone express
who they are and
who they want to be so
i think that's the good thing about our
environment at the moment
like that
speaking of that uh what's your best tic
toc
you've done a few good ones eh
yeah
well during covert i was doing our
trick shots
oh yeah
yeah but
when we went to um africa
me vincent
devin flanders then there's one tick
tock and i've got a few likes but
i'd say that was the end of it
one and one one end up
oh when you clock it on first attempt
you may as well retire right okay last
question last question and you've
already mentioned this you said that you
don't have good advice but
uh we'll see after this question best
piece of advice you have for a wider led
listener i think you've got something
good for us
um
i was gonna i was gonna try and make up
something like
you can
i was gonna do the old don't put your
egg all your eggs in one basket sort of
thing but that's just not me man
i'd say just enjoy every moment you can
yeah
mate
and no one looks like they have more fun
out on the field or off the field than
big izzy from gizzy well that's that's
one of my goals every week
have fun yeah fun
like it simple
but harder to do than people think eh
yeah definitely in the old
professional environment it is a bit
harder to fill the outside things coming
at you but if you can try to do that
it's it's pretty sweet
how good mate love it love it what a lad
you are really appreciate you come on
the podcast mate it's been awesome to go
through your journey um i knew you were
led i've known from the start since we
met as a young fella um just out of
gizzy training with the hurricanes
absolute legend but it's all been
awesome to see what you've gone on to do
and and like i said bolter for 2023
world cup in my opinion yeah well you
could put me in your fantasy team first
jab
well now you're back playing you've come
right in contention that's for sure
meters tackle breaks line breaks i know
you're a ball plus so definitely a good
shout for me this weekend
hopefully captain captain
[Laughter]
i won't be captaining a lock it's very
hard to get points for a lot to be fair
but um definitely a good shout out
i appreciate you coming on the podcast
brother it's been awesome sweetness
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]